aquí se fabrican estibas y otros
suministros para los envíos en esta
pequeña fábrica de berlín que floreció
durante los años de merkel
estamos al máximo de capacidad esta
compañía familiar ha pasado por crisis
económicas pero siempre ha estado en
buenas manos dice su jefa gabriel
costner integrante del partido
conservador
nuestras exportaciones han ido bien en
estos últimos años la señora merkel es
la política número uno en el mundo y su
buena reputación se ha hecho sentir en
nuestros productos toxina psp en 16 años
el desempleo ha caído a la mitad nunca
ha sido tan fácil encontrar un trabajo
en alemania
antes para encontrar un buen trabajo
tenías que ir a austria pero ahora una
vez tengas una buena preparación no es
un problema encontrar trabajo aquí en
alemania pero no todo es color de rosa
una quinta parte de los empleados tienen
trabajos temporales en el sector de
servicios salud o economía digital los
bajos salarios están aumentando la
inequidad 13 millones de alemanes son
considerados como pobres incluyendo a 3
millones de niños de calificación
sacaste esta ong recibe a diario algunos
de sus pequeños para darles comida y
ayuda académica durante el coi 19 mis
padres perdieron sus trabajos y nosotros
no tenemos mucho dinero ellos nos ayudan
aquí pero también nos podemos divertir
con ellos ayudan a unos 7.000 niños en
20 ciudades de alemania y están
creciendo únete saxon se ha puesto a
nuestros niños a un lado y la pandemia
lo ha hecho y si tienen problemas
financieros y educativos cuando los
padres no tienen una buena educación no
pueden ayudar a sus niños la brecha
entre los ricos y pobres en alemania
sigue abriéndose ahora la mitad de la
población controla el 99 5% de la
riqueza